[Música]
a
treinta años después de su creación el
mercosur pasa por horas bajas debido a
la posición y sol accionista del
presidente jair bolsonaro este acuerdo
ya tuvo efectos positivos en brasil
permitió la libre circulación de
personas y aumentó la estabilidad
disipando la histórica desconfianza
entre brasil y argentina sin embargo
ahora tanto el mercosur como los brics
pasan por un momento de hibernación
según dicen fuentes diplomáticas debido
precisamente a la postura política de
bolsonaro ya las diferencias ideológicas
que él mantiene con el actual gobierno
de argentina además una parte importante
de ese acuerdo que es el acuerdo entre
la unión europea y el mercosur también
está bloqueado debido a la política
medioambiental de brasil el aumento de
los índices de deforestación hay que
recordar que el mercosur reúne a más de
295 millones de personas es la quinta
economía del mundo y el año pasado en
plena pandemia realiza unas
exportaciones por el valor de 2
50.000 millones de dólares su futuro es
incierto porque bolsonaro es
imprevisible
[Música]
con argentina en la presidencia
pro-témpore el mercosur cumple 30 años
en un contexto de crisis por la pandemia
pero también por cuestiones internas del
bloque nació con la idea de avanzar
hacia un mercado común y potencial las
economías de sus miembros o un primer
impulso hacia esos objetivos y en lo
social se mejoró la movilidad de las
personas entre países del bloque con
facilidades para residir y trabajar hoy
en argentina sin embargo muchos ven al
mercosur como un ancla 1 porque
consideran la competencia de los
productos brasileños el más poderoso
miembro del bloque como una amenaza y
otros porque entienden que el mercosur
debe abrirse más al mundo y reducir
barreras al comercio aunque por ahora
están estancados importantes acuerdos de
libre comercio con otros países
especialmente con la unión europea en
todo caso a pesar de las críticas y en
el marco de una creciente centralidad de
china en los intercambios globales el
mercosur y especialmente brasil siguen
siendo el principal socio comercial de
argentina
[Música]
a 30 años del tratado de asunción que
inició el mercosur el bloque regional es
visto por distintos sectores paraguayos
con más sombras que luces uno de esos
sectores es el de los empresarios que
históricamente tuvo obstáculos para
vender sus productos en argentina brasil
a pesar de los acuerdos arancelarios las
asimétricas economías de cada país se
siguen imponiendo hoy el govern de
paraguay se suma al reclamo de uruguay y
brasil de una mayor flexibilización que
permita a cada país realizar de forma
independiente acuerdos bilaterales esta
idea sin embargo es vista con mucha
cautela en paraguay donde el 64 por
ciento de las exportaciones en 2020
fueron al mercosur en el ámbito político
la sanción de impuesta al país por el
bloque en 2012 tras la destitución de
fernando lugo aún causa mucha irritación
en aquellos sectores que impulsaron el
juicio político visto en su momento por
el mercosur como un golpe parlamentario
finalmente la incapacidad de una compra
conjunta entre los países del bloque de
vacunas contra el coronavirus desató aún
más críticas en paraguay debido a que el
país hoy se encuentra con uno de los
peores registros de vacunación contra el
coi 19 en todo
[Música]